joining me now is lieutenant christopher
oliveiras of the texas department of
public safety christopher thanks so much
for joining us today
um you know the sheer numbers of people
are so troubling coming over the border
but another huge concern is the amount
of drugs pouring over the border as well
we have some numbers we want to put up
on the screen
recently texas safety officials have
sieved
seized hundreds of pounds of cocaine and
fentanyl with a street value of 2.2
million dollars take a look at the
numbers here uh cocaine fentanyl heroin
marijuana and meth uh what do you make
of all of this i mean it's it's not like
we didn't have a drug problem before
right you're correct so we've always had
these issues on the southern border but
not to the extent that we're seeing now
with these historic numbers and that's
why governor abbott launched operation
lone star because of the current
administration's failures to secure the
border so right now our focus is to
crack down on criminal activity illegal
immigration
try to put a stop to these high-speed
dangerous pursuits because these human
smugglers are very bold and right now
we're seeing them do things that they've
never done before as far as the extent
that they're driving the rectus driving
uh they put these immigrants in danger
by the way they drive not only that but
the motoring public as well and we
continue to see that to increase because
of this current surge that's taking
place right now yeah and no doubt it
only makes your job even harder
you know and as for the people pouring
over the border let's take a look at the
cover of the new york post
this is showing border patrol agents
resorting to plugging up a 20-foot gap
in the wall with old tires and
construction materials left by former
federal contractors i mean this seems
ridiculous
it is that shouldn't be taking place
right now there should be a measure in
place where that wall should be
continuing to be constructed that's why
right now because of operation loansar
and the initiatives that governor abbott
launched
uh we have already began to construct
border fencing in the del rio sector by
using the texas military department and
because of that we are now enforcing we
are now making a rest on illegal
immigrants that are criminal trespass
and for criminal mischief so we are
putting these illegal immigrants in jail
and we are prosecuting them to the
fullest extent of the law so we're
taking those measures we're stepping in
and we're cracking down on that because
right now the current administration is
fighting to do that
yeah and you're saying that that wall
that's being constructed there in texas
is helping your situation
well i mean right now we have we have
plenty of resources that are being
provided because we have a lot of
support from governor abbott from the
texas legislators the lieutenant
governor so right now we are providing 1
000 texas department of public safety
resources to the southern border along
with the texas military military
department so right now
we're doing we can with the resources
and the capabilities that we have to
enforce these laws because right now the
federal government's not doing this job
and border patrol stretched in so we're
doing what we can to help our federal
partners as much as possible yeah yeah
of course you're only doing what you can
and and finally another migrant caravan
is now heading to the u.s border from
the city of tapachula i believe that's
in southern mexico filled with women and
children is there anything to be done
about how much
our border patrol agents like you can
take and we know we need more on the
ground and a quick answer here please
so real quick so yes i mean right now
this situation's out of control and
unless the administration steps in and
does something put some stiffer policies
in place um we're going to continue to
see these historic numbers uh month in
and month out so right now
nothing's being done on their part but
the state of texas is stepping in and
doing what we can to keep our community
safe and to keep the nation safe
well we appreciate it i guess they say
don't mess with texas for a reason right
uh christopher oliveiras thank you so
much for joining us and best of luck to
you on the ground
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now